what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video today I want to
talk about the red witch of Westeros
Melisandre in this video I'm going to
list several different people that I
think could end up killing Melisandre
during season seven I initially thought
that Melisandre had a role to play in
the end game but I'm not so sure anymore
when season 6 ended it appeared that
Melisandre time was running out right
before the Battle of the bastards began
Davos went for a walk around the camp
but he ended up finding the wooden stag
that he had given the princess Shireen
the toy was now black and didn't burned
endeavors knew right away wood had taken
place
he knew that Melisandre sacrifice
princess Shireen by burning her alive
after the battle was over in Winterfell
was back under the stark banners Davos
confronted Melisandre while she was
talking with Jon Davos forced her to
admit what she had done and even though
Jon had barely known princess Shireen
you could tell that it affected him
emotionally
Davos finished Jon to execute Melisandre
after she had admitted to killing
Shireen but Jon told her to ride south
immediately and if she ever returned to
the north he would have her hanged as a
murderer then Davos told her if he ever
saw her around there again he would
execute her himself
Melisandre then got on her horse and we
see her leaving Winterfell while Jon is
outside what sahn's up at the time we
weren't exactly sure where she would go
but thanks to the season 7 trailer we
now know that Melisandre went back to
dragonstone which does make perfect
sense
she really had nowhere else to go and
Dragonstone was once her home while she
was advising Stannis so she must have
one back there thinking it was more or
less unoccupied but it's her journey to
Dragonstone that could get interesting I
think one of the biggest theories still
out there is that Arya Stark and
Melisandre will cross paths again
now that Melisandre is heading south in
Oriya we'll be heading north this is the
perfect time for them to meet again if
you remember back in season 3 Arya and
Gendry will put the Brotherhood without
banners and at the time again she
planned on staying with the Brotherhood
to be there Smith he said they were a
family and he's never had a family of
his own but the Brotherhood ended up
having other plans for Gendry when
Melisandre showed up looking for him
Thoris and Barret ended up selling
injury to Melisandre and this did not
sit well with Arya she knew exactly what
Melisandre was going to do she knew that
Melisandre had evil intentions and that
she was going to hurt ginjury which made
Arya fear
so she confronted him Alessandra and
that's when Melisandre grabbed Aria by
the face and she said I see a darkness
in you and in that darkness eyes staring
back at me brown eyes blue eyes green
eyes eyes you'll shut forever we will
meet again ever since Melisandre said
this to aria we've all been waiting for
this day to come in during season seven
we just might get this potential fatal
reunion Melisandre is heading south to
Dragonstone an aria is currently at the
twins but she will eventually go north
back to Winterfell
and this is when Aria could get her
revenge because as of right now she must
assume that Gendry is dead the last time
aria saw injury he was being taken away
by Melisandre and she hasn't heard a
word from him since Melisandre is still
on Orias list and right now Aria is on a
mission to scratch all those names off
of that list but there is also a chance
that Aria and Melisandre do meet again
without aria even knowing that it's her
we can assume that Melisandre makes it
safely to Dragonstone because we see her
there in the trailer but there is still
a chance that they meet again while they
are both traveling which would explain
how Milla saundra made it to Dragonstone
alive about a month or two ago the
actress who portrays Melisandre posted a
picture to her Instagram account and
into picture Melisandre is getting her
makeup done for season seven based off
this photo we know that Melisandre is
going to appear as a much older woman
once again it takes hours and hours to
apply this makeup so I don't think
they'd be doing this unless they planned
on filming it I think Melisandre may
travel south as the old woman
we know that Melisandre is all alone in
traveling as a beautiful woman all alone
in this world is very dangerous but if
she travels as her natural self which is
an extremely old lady the chances of
someone trying to rape and murder her or
a lot less likely to happen if she's
traveling as an old woman she can cross
paths with Aria and she won't even know
that it's her considering they're both
going to be heading directly at each
other this is going to be a good time
for them to meet again but we know that
Aria doesn't kill her because we see her
on Dragonstone in the trailer so I'm
thinking Melisandre may travel under
disguise as the old woman in order to
keep herself safe but even if Melisandre
is able to sneak past Aria and make it
to Dragonstone she can still potentially
be killed while she is at Dragonstone
I think injury could end up be
and the one to kill her one day meet
again we've seen dozens of photos this
offseason of actors on Dragonstone and
in a number of those photos we can see
Gendry is still alive and kick'n ginjury
knows exactly what Melisandre planned on
doing to him and I definitely think
these two will see each other again on
Dragonstone and this might not end well
for Melisandre who's already in hot
water as it is not only will Gendry see
Melisandre again but Gendry and Davos
can both confront her at the same time
we've seen Davos and Gendry and photos
together on Dragonstone as well so what
do you think these two are going to say
to her when they meet Melisandre again
and they see that she's still alive and
most likely trying to counsel Daenerys
now Jon ordered Melisandre to go south
or else he would have her hang for the
murder of Shireen how was Jon going to
react when Gendry in his most trusted
advisor Davos tell him that Melisandre
tried to sacrifice Gendry also I don't
think this is going to sit well with Jon
I don't think he's going to continue to
put up with that [ __ ] and we already
know how Davos feels about her when
Davos sees that she's still alive and
now with Daenerys that's really going to
piss him off he already made remarks to
her about leaving Stannis and swearing
fealty to Jon and now she's probably
going to be up Danny's ass
I feel like Melisandre could end up
getting her ass thrown off of that cliff
at Dragonstone ginjury does have a good
heart and he's not a killer like most
men in Westeros but I can definitely see
him wanting to retaliate when he sees
Melisandre again he knows she was going
to sacrifice him and I think once John
learns of this - Melisandre can
definitely be executed now I don't see
her being given another chance no way in
hell someone is going to end up killing
her whether that be Jon Snow
sir Davos Arya Stark or ginjury is still
up for debate but her time is definitely
running out comment below and tell me
what she thinks going to happen to
Melisandre next season
how will joining Davos react when they
see her again what will Gendry do when
he finds out she is there or do you
think Arya is still going to meet her
later in the season or in season 8 and
put her out of her misery and scratch
her name off of the list let me know
what you think down below thanks for
stopping by and watching the video I
appreciate all the support and feedback
you always give me I want to thank my
patreon supporters for their kind
donations to the channel as well I'll
see you all down in the comments bye
[Music]